Navy SEALs are among the most elite
military units in the world the buds
training has a pass rate ranging from
twenty to thirty percent and it ends in
a brutal four-day challenge called hell
week where you spend four days and
nights training continuously with only
four hours sleep total and yet the
physical requirement in order to take
part in this training is only to be able
to do six to ten pull-ups the sources
vary slightly and in order to be
competitive it's recommended you be able
to do fifteen to twenty but the point is
it's not that much physical fitness and
strength they are not the most important
criteria for becoming a Navy SEAL so
what is that would be mental toughness
the ability to go through such a
rigorous and grueling training and not
give up not quit hence the dropout rates
and the same is true if you look at many
different historical warrior cultures
the Spartans in particular did not train
like athletes or like bodybuilders
instead they focus primarily on being
able to perform whether it was
blisteringly hot or freezing cold at
high altitudes and on little sleep
they'd wear a cloak made out of thin
material called a foil NICUs and sustain
themselves on something called black
broth they're intentionally not given
enough and they're encouraged if they
needed more to try and steal it from
other students and there was harsh
punishment if they're caught stealing
even though it was encouraged they will
bear feet in their chance to do things
like ripping weeds out of riverbeds for
hours on end this kind of training
wasn't about building strength and mass
but instead building a kind of warriors
mindset that would allow them to keep
training keep pushing themselves no
matter what the conditions this mental
toughness is something that is of course
a huge asset in productivity in working
out and getting into shape and it's
something that we could all cultivate
more unfortunately our lifestyles are so
comfortable
we're so unused to being uncomfortable
that we often will collapse at the first
sign of challenge using a little bit of
this kind of training we can get past
that and therefore stay committed to our
goals no matter what to mood we're in so
what is mental toughness really well we
could liken it to a psychological trait
known as hardness first suggested by
psychologists cabassa hardness describes
our ability to thrive in or at least
endure highly stressful experiences
someone who is Hardy is able to continue
working to stay focused and even healthy
despite being extremely stressed for
long periods of course this is extremely
useful
for somebody going through something
like hell week CEOs and managers are
often found to have high levels of
hardiness they're able to focus despite
being extremely stressed this is
actually why a lot of psychopaths end up
becoming highly successful CEOs and
that's something I'm going to return to
in a future video Hardiness can also
prevent something called learned
helplessness which is kind of the
opposite of hardiness this is where you
learn to give up where you've failed so
many times that you just stop trying and
this is linked with depression and a
host of other mental health issues and
in one study was found that the very top
performing elite athletes and military
personnel would demonstrate a heightened
arousal during highly stressful
activities but also greater sympathetic
response at rest in other words they
could get more amped up more psyched up
when they were training or when they
were facing a challenge or when they're
in warfare however when they were
relaxing when they were grabbing that
downtime they're able to calm down much
quicker and feel less stressed this was
important for recovery which then would
allow them to go again harder when they
needed to of course if you were going
through hell week and you only had four
hours of sleep you need to make every
hour count and so this would become
extremely important it has also been
linked in other research to higher
levels of neuropeptide Y and DHEA in the
brain DHEA is known to buffer the
effects of cortisol in the hippocampus
in other words it allows us to maintain
use of our higher order cognitive
functions to plan ahead to think
strategically even when we're highly
stressed whether this is something
innate or whether it's something that
can be trained is unclear certainly
tropics and herbs can also increase the
production of DHEA and neuropeptide Y in
particular adaptogen such as ashwagandha
and I have done a video on creating a
flow stack so check that if you want to
learn more about that what's also really
important is metacognition metacognition
is thinking about thinking in other
words reflecting on your thought
patterns and how they're going to
influence your mood and your motivation
and discipline so what kind of
strategies and techniques can use in
order to make yourself more disciplined
and to increase mental toughness one
example is something called eating the
whole elephant this rather strange
sounding example refers to the ability
to break down what is an overwhelming
seeming task into smaller much more
manageable chunks so in this example
you're tasked with eating an entire
elephant for some reason and just
thinking about that is enough to make
you want to give up so
instead of thinking about that instead
focus on each mouthful
each small plate that way it becomes
much easier to just grow through to
focus on those small challenges to the
big macro goal takes care of itself
in the gym instead of trying to do one
minute of battle ropes it might mean
instead that you're doing 6 times 10
seconds of battle rope 10 seconds is
nothing you can do six of those right
another strategy is something called 4
by 4 by 4 and this is a breathing
technique that I have touched on on this
channel in the past and it's also used
by Yogi's and several others it's also
called a box breathing in order to use
this type of breathing you'll breathe in
for four seconds hold your breath before
seconds breathe out for four seconds and
then hold your breath for four seconds
by doing this you not only bring your
focus internally we also send signals
via the vagus nerve to your autonomic
nervous system in other words you're
calming yourself down you're telling
yourself that everything's okay this is
sometimes referred to as arousal control
and there are many other techniques you
can use
- such as meditation or anchoring etc
another very interesting one is
something called a non reactivity is
basically the mental toughness
equivalent of a flow State so you're
tuning out you're zoning out and you're
leaving your thoughts behind instead of
stressing and worrying about how
challenging what you're doing is or how
much further you have to go you're
instead just forgetting all that and
focusing on that moment it's a little
bit like mindfulness if you push
yourself hard enough and long enough
then you'll probably experience this
naturally swimmers experience something
similar and they call that a swim coma
where they just forget about everything
and just keep doing stroke by stroke
until they complete their goal once
you've achieved this once you'll find
it's easier to get back into this state
and to tap into huge reserves of energy
you didn't know you had you can also
improve your chances of acquiring it by
using mindfulness meditation and by
adopting a stoic mindset stoic
philosophy teaches us not to worry about
trying to create a perfect life for
ourselves not trying to make everything
comfortable and nice but instead just
accepting that bad things happen and all
you can control is your reaction to that
by doing this you learn to detach
yourself from what's happening and to
just do what needs to be done finally
another form of metacognition you can
use to enhance your mental toughness is
something called CBT or cognitive
behavioral therapy this is a psycho
therapeutic tool which basically
involves looking at the contents of your
thoughts and what's negative what's
damaging and then replacing those with
more positive and useful thoughts I've
done a whole video on this in the past I
won't beat a dead horse now
but suffice to say that by identifying
which thoughts are leading you to quit
and then eliminating those you can make
it much harder for yourself to give up
when the going gets rough for instance
if you're going for a long run or if
you're carrying kettlebells for a
farmer's walk you might feel your body
screaming and then give up because in
the back of your mind you think you're
going to injure yourself if you don't
this isn't a conscious thought you don't
actually think you're going to injure
yourself but if you dig really deep
there's a small element of that and you
use that as an excuse to put down the
weights and to sit down for a bit
however David Goggins suggests something
called be 40% rule the 40% rule tells us
that when our body starts telling us to
quit and when we think we've used up all
of our reserves we've actually only used
40% you have another 60% in the tank
whilst that's a very general sweeping
statement there is some truth in it and
you can certainly carry those
kettlebells an extra hundred meters with
no worries of injuring yourself and
feeling it too badly the next day
likewise I've done some personal
reflection and found that when I'm
feeling tired or too exhausted to work
or be productive or to work out it often
comes down to the fact that I'm trying
to kind of preserve my tiredness and at
the same time I'm trying to communicate
with other people that I'm tired so I
don't get asked to do stuff this isn't a
conscious attempt to shirk my
responsibilities it's a kind of deep
down subtle thing but I know it's there
now and I can address it if I exercise
if I get productive I'll have a boost of
energy and I can get more done and
actually that's a much better thing to
communicate to other people as well
there's no point getting disheartened
and sulking when something goes wrong
there's no point giving up when the
going gets tough so why do you do it
time to do some soul-searching all these
tips are great on paper and they can
certainly be useful but they're not
going to do much unless you actually try
putting them into practice in other
words put yourself in those positions in
those situations where the going is
tough and where you have to push through
like I said at the start of this video
we're all too used to being comfortable
and we're all too unused to being
uncomfortable and so this is something
you need to reintroduce into your life
David Goggins describes this as building
calluses for your mind just like you
train your muscles just like you might
train your memory you can also train
your mental toughness and your hardiness
if you already workout and this is a
step in the right direction however you
probably workout in a nice warm plush
health spa and just for a set period of
time where you set the rules and
not really enough instead how about
getting outside training barefoot in the
cold and doing things that you find
really uncomfortable maybe add some fat
gripz your weights to make them thicker
so it hurts your arms and challenging
yourself with things that you don't find
easy that don't come naturally don't do
more of what you're good at don't get
stronger if you're ready really strong
how about improving your mobility itself
outside your comfort zone and that's how
you'll build that kind of mental
toughness likewise how about working out
a lobby when you're very tired or just
pushing yourself really far by setting
challenges for yourself how about
working out in the snow while working
out fasted us memory champion Ron White
described how he hired a Navy SEAL in
order to help train him for competition
and one of the things that that Navy
SEAL taught him was not to memorize
cards on land in a nice warm environment
with the kids shut out of the room with
complete silence but rather to try and
memorize them underwater in scuba gear
the thought was if he could memorize a
pack of cards in the water and doing so
on land would be easy
likewise when Ron found himself very ill
one day his coach forced him to carry on
training anyways because he said what
would you do if you were ill on the day
I've often thought what would Batman do
if he was attacked by all his enemies at
once on a day when he had a really bad
cold
of course he's Batman so he would have
trained for that as well just to be
clear I'm not recommending that you do
anything that's gonna cause you harm I'm
not recommending that you do super high
repetitions of deadlifts for instance
CrossFit can help you develop a
fantastic mental toughness but it's not
a good idea to end yourself in the
process that's why I think it's a much
better idea to do this sort of thing
using push-ups or even farmers walks
something that's far less likely to
cause injury
likewise I don't recommend that you
sleep deprived yourself but you can if
you're already sleep deprived force
yourself to Train anyways once again
using only very simple movements that
won't cause an injury likewise I don't
recommend that you work out ill likewise
you can make other things less
comfortable too taking cold showers is
fantastic for building mental toughness
and at the same time it's actually
really healthy for you
likewise training outside in the cold or
training in bare feet is really healthy
for you
you can mimic Ron by training yourself
to be more effective in work by working
in less comfortable environments that's
why I might start trying to force myself
now occasionally to work to the same
level even when there is a noise behind
me or a distraction that way when I come
back to work and it's quiet I should
find it much easier to have been that
much more productive that much more
consistently one of the very simplest
things you can do is to work out when
you're not
like it when you're just tired at the
end of a day if you have the mental
toughness to work out even if it's just
for ten minutes when you really don't
feel like it then not only will you find
it easier to stick to anything you don't
want to do to chase after any goal but
at the same time you'll get into much
better shape much more quickly simply
because you're able to train whenever
you get the opportunity you can develop
that kind of mental toughness and if you
can incorporate it into your training
and I think you'll see fantastic results
and it might actually be more
game-changing than any change in your
technique or any new exercise protocol
in short stop trying to find ways to
make your workouts
easier and more comfortable find ways to
make them harder and more difficult and
see that as part of the workout so I
found this video useful interesting guys
if you did then please leave a like
comment down below and let me know if
you have any tips for building mental
toughness subscribe if you want to see
more like this I have lots more on the
way and of course guys you can still get
my ebook and full training program super
functional training from the link in the
description down below and of course
I'll see you next time thanks a ton and
bye for now
[Music]